what does this feel like all of this for
your movie what a big day it is such a
big day it feels great we're all so
proud of the lego movie it's yeah it's
it's been very successful and critically
adored which is good and yeah we're here
too just today is about celebrating what
we've accomplished over the five years
since the first movie works very hard
and and soon you'll be able to see the
movie
what is Jack more impressed with the
fact that you're in the Lego movies and
you can bring him to stuff like this or
you're outdoorsy skills
oh I mean look I'm dad you know
everything that does is awesome yeah
it's hard to compare apples to oranges
but he loved all the Lego I get to bring
home that's pretty cool but at the end
of the day I think he likes go to the
farm more yeah I guess if you have to
compare it he loves them both very we're
very blessed blessed family is a lucky
boy any chance you're gonna be at the
Oscars presenting dollies I'm still
hoping I'll get nominated for a Jurassic
world fallen Kingdom but you know we'll
see congratulations we haven't seen you
for hour you must be so excited why is
she the right woman for you oh god I
just wouldn't even be able to crunch it
into a sound bite you know if we could
sit down and talk about it I would tell
you all about it but but unfortunately
it's too busy to do that so do you have
plans for the wedding me this year okay
[Music]